por fin un respiro para los haitianos
luego de dos meses sin suministro las
estaciones de gasolina abrieron en Haití
bajo fuertes medidas de seguridad un
gran alivio para los conductores aunque
se quejan por los altos precios
impuestos por las autoridades
Quiero conseguir gasolina mejor precios
no quiero tener que ir a buscarla en las
calles donde el precio es muy alto
además la gasolina es muy mala y podría
romper el motor del auto
el 12 de septiembre la coalición de
pandillas g9 liderada por alias barbacoa
se había tomado de la terminal barrow
encargada del almacenamiento del 70% del
combustible del país las pandillas Se
tomaron la central luego de días de
violentas protestas tras el anuncio de
la finalización de subsidios al
combustible por parte del Primer
Ministro ají el ángel el país se
paralizó económicamente y entró en una
fuerte crisis humanitaria que
imposibilitó la distribución de agua
potable clave para combatir un rebrote
de cólera que según informó el
Ministerio de salud ha dejado más de
1.700 sospechas de contagio y 40 muertes
el primer combustible que salió de la
terminal se dirigió a fábricas
hospitales y otras instituciones
públicas
por fin podemos respirar porque el país
se paralizó por la escasez de
combustible por fin Hoy podemos
encontrar algo de combustible que nos
haga felices
toda la población sintió el efecto de la
escasez de combustible porque es un
producto esencial
durante el tiempo del bloqueo el mercado
negro comerciaba la gasolina a unos 30
dólares por galón un precio que muy
pocos podían pagar